[music]
behind me is the
administration before a full-scale
invasion, the Russian woman was civilized by the
administrations of this area
for the sake of today in earlier
850 rolls not a word and expression in the soup
I will surprise us Nazarov past and mosin for
large family 22 was especially
ready to wear brewed take out  skoda has a
pair of nervous rams now carved stupa it’s
not hard for me the girl died on mine that’s
all I can say you will save the ice
dear passed attracted
people very new topics were afraid everyone ran into the
corridor and still they themselves
there someone left but  someone is afraid and
immediately announced an alarm, then a
very strong noise of the waves began abruptly, everything began to lose weight,
I looked, well, I didn’t see the plane, it
’s a rocket for the body, and
well, as if I know what to
do, I clung to the house, took the
dog lay down on the ground  it covered and a second later,
as the explosion sounded, a wave went off,
it all flew glass fragments, as it were,
but got up, painted, looked,
got into the store,
but